Okay.
Please allow me just the briefest diversion
from horrible things happening the world over
and in the United States to mention something
very exciting and positive, which is that
the David Pakman show YouTube channel has
achieved and surpassed 900000 subscribers.
In fact, I think we now are probably closer
to nine.
No one yet, just shy of 900 and 1000 already.
This happened yesterday during a live stream.
In fact, rolling over from eight hundred and
ninety nine thousand subscribers to nine hundred
thousand YouTube subscribers.
And so now the race to one million officially
begins.
Now, about 18 months ago, we were already
starting to look at, you know, could we get
to a million by Election Day?
It could happen 18 months out.
It's sort of hard to know if things go well.
We could maybe hit a million subscribers before
the 2020 election.
We still could, although we're a little bit
behind right now.
According to Social Blade, based on recent
growth trends were expected to hit a million
subscribers on January 9th.
So that would be before the inauguration.
But about two months after the election, however,
it's not impossible.
So rough numbers.
We're 97 days from Election Day and we're
ninety nine thousand subscribers short of
a million.
So call it you know, it's like one hundred
thousand.
We need about a thousand thirty new subscribers
a day from here on out to hit a million by
Election Day.
This actually isn't crazy.
The last few weeks we've been getting thirteen
hundred a day.
We only need a thousand thirty a day.
So we just have to hold that and then we can
do it now.
This is really wild.
I was looking back at old numbers.
You know what the David Pakman show launched
on YouTube a long time ago and we did it because
Jank Yuga from the Young Turks who I met in
2008.
At a radio conference, I told them what I
was doing.
And he said, you know, you should throw some
cameras in your studio.
Start putting the videos on YouTube.
It could be big.
YouTube could be big.
That's what Genk said to me.
And so we started filming the show and it
took us five years to get our first hundred
thousand subscribers on YouTube to go from
zero to one hundred thousand.
It took five years.
The next hundred thousand took only a year
and five months.
We then got our next hundred thousand and
only eleven months.
We then went from 300000 to 400000 in eight
months.
Then things sort of slowed down a little.
It took us 10 months for the next hundred
thousand.
It took us eight months to get to 600000.
Took us another only four months to get to
700000 subscribers.
Seven to eight hundred thousand.
Took seven months and it only took us five
months to go from 800000 to 900000 subscribers.
We have just over three months to get to a
million.
It would be the fastest gain of 100000 subscribers
since we've started.
But let's go for it.
Let's go for it.
And by the way, I also want to start hearing
ideas from people about what to do to celebrate
getting to one million.
Send me ideas.
A few people wrote in and said I should dye
my hair some color and it should be subject
to maybe people voting on what the color would
be.
I mean, I guess I would maybe do that.
My hair color doesn't really lend itself.
I'd have to probably totally bleach it first
to dry it.
I don't know that that's particularly good.
You know, some of these chemical elements,
so to speak, aren't exactly the best.
My guesses.
I'm not ruling it out, but my guesses people
can probably come up with something more clever
than just dyeing my hair to do it.
One million YouTube subscribers.
And meanwhile, fortunately, the show is growing
on other platforms as well.
So I'm not doing like a full state of the
show address here for you today.
But we have surpassed 40000 followers on our
Twitch channel, which is great.
The audio podcast is has grown like 20 percent
per month for the last two, three months,
which has really given us a big, big boost.
And it's extraordinary to see more people
engaging with us on that platform.
So a lot of good things, needless to say.
Send me your ideas for what to do to celebrate
one million subscribers, assuming we get there.
I don't know that it's a matter of if.
I think it's more a matter of when I want
it to be before Election Day.
Imagine if it was on Election Day.
Imagine if as we defeat Donald Trump, if we
do, we surpass one million subscribers.
I'd have to blow out memberships for two bucks
a year.
Right.
I'd have to do something completely unprecedented
if that happened.
But send me your ideas and we'll follow up
and discuss more.